FELIPE HOFFA: In a world with
almost 500 sessions at Next
2018, it's understandable that
you couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see how
Geotab drives smart city
innovation using
BigQuery, then stay tuned,
because here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hola!
My name is Felipe Hoffa.
You're interested in cool
ways to analyze data.
Prepare to rewind.
I chose this talk
because it highlights
some of the coolest new
features in BigQuery--
geography functions
and BigQuery ML.
Yes.
BigQuery now has
native functions
that understand geography.
And now you can also use
BigQuery to create and execute
machine learning models
in the database--
in SQL, where your data lives.
In this talk, we can see
how Bob and Daniel at Geotab
use these new BigQuery
features together
to predict how road
traffic in a city
will change under any
set of conditions.
Geotab is a company that already
has more than one petabyte
of data stored in BigQuery,
with data points collected
from millions of vehicles
moving around the world.
But before getting
into the big demo,
our BigQuery Product
Manager, Chad Jennings,
explains what is BigQuery
and the significance
of these amazing new features.
BigQuery is our
serverless data warehouse
that you can use to store
and analyze all of your data,
no matter what size.
And all you need to know is SQL.
Now we're adding native
geography functions
to BigQuery, so
companies like Geotab
can analyze the real-world data
in even more powerful ways.
Let's say you have a point
in the world, or a line,
or a polygon, or an arbitrary
collection of things.
BigQuery now has a new
geography data type that
can encapsulate any of this.
And once you have
geography elements,
BigQuery can operate over them.
You can ask for measures
like distance, length, area,
or transform these geographies
with unions and differences,
or find out if they
intersect, or are contained
between each other,
and even join tables
based on these predicates.
Is the world a perfect sphere?
Nope.
And BigQuery now
understands that.
We even created a new tool to
easily visualize the results
of your SQL queries--
the BigQuery Geo Viz tool.
And then, with BigQuery ML,
you can create machine learning
models where your data lives.
Your data analysts
and scientists
can create an
experimental wheel,
finding the best
features within your data
to create predictions
inside the data warehouse
and without sweat.
Train, evaluate, predict!
[SNAPS]
And what happens when we
put everything together?
Well, now you can
watch the full talk
to see some of the many
ways in which Geotab
uses their data in BigQuery
to create smarter cities.
If you would like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to
subscribe to the GCP YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]